Дональд Трамп на брифінгу в Білому домі висловив упевненість,
що падіння ціни на нафту марки WTI до негативних показників -
це явище лише тимчасове.
І пояснюється воно, на думку президента США, в основному фінансовими причинами.
Це більше фінансове питання, ніж ситуація з нафтою.
Я впевнений, що приблизно через місяць ціна буде 25 або 28 доларів за барель.
Тож, в основному - це фінансовий тиск.
А заступник голови Радбезу Росії Дмитро Медведєв
взагалі порівняв ситуацію з ф'ючерсами на нафту з картельною змовою.
Проте експерти вважають, що причини пов’язані не тільки з ринковими спекуляціями.
Ми зіткнулися з різким скороченням пересувань людей через карантинні заходи
- майже ніхто не літає і не відвозить дітей у школи.
Падіння попиту становить, за різними оцінками, 30-35 відсотків,
і нафтовий ринок не був готовий до таких змін.
Трамп заявив, що на тлі небувало низьких цін США заповнять свої стратегічні сховища.
Втім, на думку експертів, навіть наявність містких нафтосховищ
не вирішує базової проблеми в галузі.
Якщо подивитися на сховища, на те, як там справи, то в Росії їх немає.
У Саудівській Аравії є, є в усьому світі.
У США 70 відсотків сховищ поблизу міста Кушінг заповнені,
але ще багато часу мине, поки не вичерпають можливості.
Є у них ще стратегічний резерв 40 мільйонів барелів,
який теж можна заповнювати комерційною нафтою.
Але головне те, що нафтопереробні заводи не приймають нафту
через те, що впав попит.
Головним способом стабілізації нафтового ринку
фахівці вважають значне скорочення нафтовидобутку,
проти якого ще на початку березня виступала Росія.
Багатьом країнам, в тому числі Канаді, США,
Мексиці, Бразилії, Росії та Казахстану,
доведеться серйозно скоротити видобуток найближчим часом.
За американською маркою WTI вниз пішли і ціни на нафту марки Brent,
впавши до мінімальних показникІв майже за 20 років.
Експерти впевнені: постраждають без винятку всі країни-експортери нафти.
Постраждають усі країни, в яких видобувається нафта.
Особливо - Саудівська Аравія, де держбюджет вкрай залежний від торгівлі нафтою
і розрахований з ціни у 80 доларів за барель.
У Росії схожа ситуація, але за основу там брали вартість у 40 доларів.
Крім скорочення бюджетних надходжень, кажуть експерти,
падіння цін на нафту впливає на курс рубля.
Сьогодні на Московській біржі долар піднявся вище позначки в 77 рублів.
Я думаю, буде девальвація рубля.
Ми бачимо вже, що на ринку рубль трохи відпустили,
і його вартість до долара падає.
Це вигідно експортерам,
але населенню в тій ситуації, коли 65 відсотків товарів імпортні, це дуже і дуже погано.
У Кремлі закликали не надавати падінню цін на нафту, цитата, апокаліптичного забарвлення
і запевнили, що зроблять все необхідне
для пом'якшення негативних наслідків для російської економіки.